foreign
this story is almost just as wild as
that one this woman from South Dakota
traveled to Tampa Bay to cheat on her
husband but wound up facing criminal
charges that's because Renee scoglin
filed a false police report while she
was here and not just a false police
report
she accused somebody of rape because she
the husband found out yeah they won't
believe what she claimed in that I'll
believe it she's a white woman a report
in why she didn't because she didn't
want to get caught they do it all the
time
come on Gloria Gomez shows up I'll
believe it Emmett Till I see it
landed her in front of a judge
you sure do you have any
questions did you just rape me judge we
could request from the court spinning
hair too man she is a [__] mess
that's how she got caught which is like
he raped me and everybody went no he
didn't all right you know what just sit
tight I'm gonna go talk to my partner
for a minute I'll be back here's
laughing through the door
[Music]
it's Florida
an illegal hot water that even surprised
the judge
this is really unbelievable skogland's
trail of Lies started on March 8th of
2023 where she decided to come to Tampa
Bay and cheat on her husband
that she had had consensual sexual
intercourse with an individual while
okay hold on hold on
I want you to look at the I want you to
look at the black lady
up front look at her eyes it's very
funny
that she had had
this dude
girl needs Jesus status and she wanted
to get checked for her sexual
transmitted diseases but she calm down
lady if you wanted to get tested I mean
everything about her is bad but that
hair is [__] atrocious wait it's
because she I'm sorry she's a Twist I
didn't know this this it's not because
she was afraid of getting caught listen
to this an individual while in
Hillsborough County oh you want to be
with her that she felt guilty about this
due to her marital status and she wanted
to get checked for a sexual transmitted
disease but she wanted to get tested for
free
so instead of paying for the STDs she
said she was raped
what a Twist holy [__] do you know by
the way ma'am there's clinics free
clinics will do it
so she decided to lie again and call
9-1-1
oh that's sometimes they have oh God I
forgot sometimes I just go to Planned
Parenthood to feel the touch of a man
okay they have they have the police call
okay even the guy on the phone the
police dispatcher knew she sounded ugly
the way he responded here once listen
one
I'm sorry
you
know
ma'am you sound ugly okay how long ago
did this happen
I don't know when did the Bills go to
the playoffs in the 90s 95 I want to say
Jim Kelly was quarterback I know that
everybody wanted
to go you lie and you say it was a long
time ago you don't know the guy even if
you are gonna I mean you don't lie about
rape obviously colglin made up a story
cost of all of this
AFC Urgent Care Watertown which is
whatever standard any Town USA offers
STD related physician consults at
affordable price of
ninety dollars ninety dollars on average
most patients pay between 50 to 100 for
initial testing if their insurance is in
network with their medical provider okay
with insurance but without insurance
you're looking like a hundred bucks
damn
all this for a hundred bucks you know
what costs more attorneys yeah Colgan
made up a store a story about having a
course
is that a condom how much is that in
likes I don't know how many likes it is
we have the convert it okay
made up a story about having car trouble
on Interstate 75 and pulling over I-75
on the side of the road road an unknown
mail approached her
put a towel over her head and forced her
into the back seat of her car oh
God what is it with rope what is why is
rope is such a funny like like it's such
an indicator that it's a made-up story
like Chelsea smallett and bubble Wallace
like like it's like clue like every time
rope is involved I'm like I'm not buying
this first first even in her wildest
rape fantasy
oh God that's right
she knows I think she's self-aware in
that Prospect
because her face was covered he was able
to achieve an erection he was able to
come
mad [__] hair you got tits in the
front and tits on the back yeah and and
like literally like you're you have hair
like Gerard Depardieu oh my God she
couldn't describe her attacker but her
story started to unravel she was black
the police checked her cell phone and
found just like late stage Livia soprano
hair oh this Walmart surveillance video
skoglin buying the Rope herself hey guys
I gotta can I can I make it please can
you give a pro tip give him a pro tip I
really need to issue a plea to anybody
who hears my words right now
if you're gonna commit crime and I
recommend you don't don't commit crimes
but if you're going to commit crimes
this kind of sloppy shit's not gonna fly
in 2023. no no driving your own car
to go do a crime because they [__]
got cameras everywhere now and they just
look it up and [__] they'll find it
they're finding bodies now because when
somebody's a suspect of like a murder or
something they just go through all the
traffic cameras and the local door
cameras and ring cameras and they'll
track your [__] car driving all the
way to a place where you dump the body
now it ain't worth it anymore to go into
a store and buy the roping and say the
Rope was used in a rape like police will
check your your financial records
they'll check your cell phone data
they'll look into it they'll see where
you were and they'll get you on camera
buying the [__] rope don't what are
you doing nowadays you gotta stop so I
went to Walmart a place with the most
cameras and I use my credit card it's
like ma'am
she confessed to making the whole thing
up she was charged with making a false
police report and decided to take a plea
deal you know they really need to make a
[__] separate I
I'm loathe to say this because I hate
more laws I hate more government but
they do need to make a separate [__]
criminal category for you it should be
equal to the to the what you get for
raping somebody because you ruined
someone's life remember that dude that
kind of [__] him in a [__] college
football player and he got [__]
because of it and then you know these
lives are ruined I never sentenced
anybody for perjury the Duke students
they got all [__] too reminders
every perjury is a crime and all this
stuff look I never [__] do for
perjury because it's a joke but this is
ridiculous you made up and the resources
expended on it
um
[Music]
will now serve two years of community
control and eight years of probation
so nothing ma'am no that's something
that's something significant yeah
because you're in a [__] now you're
in a legal
you're in legal quicksand for eight
years like you're better off taking I
would if I would have asked the D.A is
there any way I could get like 60 days
six months in jail something like that
I'd rather just get it done because once
you eight years of probation that means
any little minor [__] up dude that's
true yeah you're not [__] [__] and
within eight years she's absolutely
gonna [__] up that probation that like
just by law of averages if you look at
even if you're not a criminal and you're
not a [__] up do you really want to bet
your whole life on eight years if you're
not getting in a little bit of trouble
like you're just losing your [__]
temper at a Wawa cause somebody's
blocking a kiss you know what I mean
something that's minor where you yelled
at a guy and he called the cops and said
I was scared and then you even just get
a little misdemeanor but now hey you
were on probation now you're getting a
violation then they bring the old
charges off the docket they re-punish
you if it it's a trap probation is a
[__] trap and I mentioned this before
because not a lot of people like legal
experts like we are but misdemeanor is
short for Missy Misdemeanor Elliott for
those who don't know yeah who made some
very great videos with Hype Williams
back in the day uh stasher when she
dressed like a garbage bag
dark comedy that dumbass probably Amazon
Prime
it seemedy's tipping competing literally
the ocean is littered with rope go to
the beach quotes every you were in Tampa
the point there's rope everywhere
critical thought
totally agree with Royce women are like
women like this need to serve the full
sentence of what they're accusing of
women who want to be Housewives don't
set women back 100 years chicks like
this do